[Music]
childhood toys are hard to get rid of
they're full of sentimental memories
that are just too difficult to let go
here's some good news you don't need to
throw them out give them an upgrade
instead it's time to bring out your
Barbie dolls don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and hit that
subscribe button now let's check out 10
genius ways you can reuse old toys toy
elephant statues remember those big
elephants you got it Playmobil or any of
those hard elephants that were a perfect
toy but are now just lying abandoned in
your house turn them into awesome
looking statues and add to your house
decor all you'll need for this is gold
spray paint and your old elephant toy we
recommend using gloves for this project
as it can get quite messy protect your
surroundings and place the elephant on a
few newspapers it's even better if you
can take this project outside spray the
elephant and leave it until dry
preferably for 24 hours then place it on
a shelf and voila your toy elephant just
turned into a modern piece of decoration
you can also use the trunk for any
jewelry and upgrade your statue into a
jewelry stand you can also experiment
with colors and create a unique modern
statue so next time you see a toy
elephant around turn it into a DIY home
decor project these are so easy and you
can easily involve your kids or your
entire family too so grab your elephant
some spray paint a couple of newspapers
go outside and have some fun with this
project don't forget to show us your
finished product small toy car mirrors
this is one of the best DIY projects
we've ever seen and from the looks of it
it can keep you occupied for quite a few
hours the end result looks like a modern
piece of decor that would look perfect
on your wall we bet you had tons of
those small toy cars as a child and if
you have children you probably still do
if you've outgrown your small toy cars
and aren't sure what to do with them how
about turning them into a mirror decor
all you'll need to make this work are a
bunch of toy
cars an old mirror and a lot of
superglue again you might want to put a
couple of newspapers under this project
to protect the surface then just glue
the cars on to the edge of the mirror
and voila you're done you can also
upgrade this project and use gold or
color spray-paint to make your toy car
mirror even more modern these are
excellent for just about any room you
don't even have to spray-paint them as
the original colorful frame also looks
pretty awesome we recommend using a high
quality glue for this one and make sure
you leave your project to dry overnight
again it's best to do this outside or
somewhere where you can't spray paint
your other furniture unless you really
want to of course then just hang it up
and admire your masterpiece if you want
to watch just one more video the premium
is the platform where you should go
get early access to videos from the
things the taco the trendy the richest
and many other great channels in one
place with ad free browsing click this
link to sign up for free to the premium
and get ready to binge watch videos from
your favorite channels skateboard
bookcase another fun project that's
slightly more advanced than spraying an
old toy is creating the ultimate
bookcase we have to admit this one does
look kind of cool do you have any
skateboards lying around your home most
of us have skateboards lying around when
we were young and although skateboarding
is still popular we bet you have
skateboards that are too old to be good
enough to ride on so why not turn them
into an actual bookcase this project
might take you a while but it's totally
worth it you'll need at least two
skateboards
a drill and you can use either threaded
rods or sturdy strings l-shaped brackets
and stopper bolts that will hold the
skateboards in place then you'll need to
drill two holes on each side of the
skateboard and put stopper bolts on the
rods put the rods through the holes add
a second skateboard attach the
l-brackets and add the whole thing to
the wall and there you have it an
awesome looking skateboard shelf spice
up your skateboards by decorating them
or painting them before you start this
pride
there are tons of possibilities with
this one but the end result looks
amazing in a teenage room another way
you can make this work is by cutting
your skateboard in half and add an
l-shaped bracket to the bottom attach
the skateboard to the bracket on one
side and add it on the wall on another
you can leave the wheels on or take them
off it's completely up to you but we're
sure that whatever you decide to do it's
going to be amazing stuffed toy chair a
lot of us have so many stuffed toys we
don't know what to do with them even as
grown-ups some of us have toys that we
just don't want to throw out because
they remind us of our childhood we'll
show you a unique way of how you can
reuse those toys and make a totally
brand-new piece of furniture the first
option is to use an old round or
recliner chair you have the more
uncomfortable the chair is the better it
will look once you're done grab your
stuffed animals along with a needle and
a thread and get to work
start sewing those animals into the
chair cushion and make sure every single
part of the chair is covered try to find
the softest and most cuddly animals keep
on going until you've sewed on every
single animal onto the chair
once you're done you'll have a brand new
awesome looking chairs that's twice as
comfortable as the original another way
to make this work is to grab all your
stuffed animals and make a comfy cushion
all you'll need is some colorful fabric
pattern pieces and a sewing machine we
don't recommend you do this by hand as
it requires a stronger clothes fill up
your animals in the fabric then use the
sewing machine to turn it into a ball
voila you've just created a cushion full
of stuffed animals stuffed animal rug
speaking of stuffed animals there's
another thing you can do if you want to
upgrade your toys but aren't ready to
throw them away yet have you ever heard
of a stuffed animal rug don't worry no
animals were harmed in the making of
this rug what you'll need for this
project are some scissors and your old
stuffed animals cut open each animal and
take out their filling until you end up
with a flat piece of fabric do the same
with all other animals and then just use
the sewing machine to put
all those pieces together use a needle
and a thread once your piece gets too
big keep going until you get to your
desired size you might have to run the
needle and the thread through a couple
of times to make strong stitches then
put it down and there you have it a
colorful and extremely soft rug made of
your favorite stuffed animals this is a
perfect addition for a kid's room and it
can even work in bathrooms if your toys
are particularly colorful you can end up
with a unique look this project can keep
you busy for a long time so we recommend
doing this as your next summer or winter
project
whoever's toys you are using just make
sure you tell them what you're planning
on doing with them first garden trucks
so how about those toy trucks your kids
or yourself have outgrown as you got
older do you remember those yellow
pickup or hauler trucks that are
probably growing old in the Attic or in
the basement well it's time to take them
out because we have another genius way
you can reuse them this one is really
simple just grab some soil put it on the
back of the truck and plant some seeds
you can also use them as a plant holder
put in your favorite cactus or any other
small plants that would fit in the back
take the truck to the next level and
paint it to match the rest of your
garden pots not only is this a genius
way of reusing your old toys but it also
makes your new plant holder totally
transportable you can even put this in a
kid's room and add a bit of flour decor
to freshen up the air or do this with
those pull along wagon trucks we bet
most of you still have one of those
somewhere in your childhood home it's
time to get them out give them a
makeover and get them to work shopkins
display shopkins craze began in 2014 and
it's still going strong if you grew up
in the 90s you might be unfamiliar with
this new brand of miniature collectibles
shopkins are miniature toys that look
like your typical grocery store items
they're absolutely adorable but kids can
easily outgrow their shopkins collection
they're tiny and can easily get lost or
left or
the house so what do you do when you're
left with a bunch of tiny toys but no
space to put them one solution is to
throw them away
another is to put them on display this
is a super simple project that can be
done in just a few minutes all you'll
need are a couple of ice trays mount
those trays on a wall and add a shopkin
into each bracket to keep them safe and
secure add a large piece of glass to
close them in you can also reuse those
basket shopkins come in those are
perfect for Easter and also work
amazingly as a plant holder as shopkins
are just as soft as any other plush toys
you can also use them in some of our
previous projects like a toy rug or sew
them onto a chair the options are
endless small toy lampstand if you loved
this small toy car mirrored decor we've
already shown you you'd love this lamp
stand made of small toys we've all grown
up with plenty of small knick-knack toys
that don't really belong to any
collections they either got lost
separated or we just love playing with
that one specific toy if you're crafty
you'll absolutely love this project
it's totally inexpensive and easy to do
plus it adds a modern piece of decor to
your house what you'll need are small
old toys really strong glue and a lamp
you can also use spray paint to turn
your toys into the same color as the
lamp then just stick the pieces together
and glue them on the lamp it doesn't
even have to be perfect
we recommend using gloves and protecting
your eyes because you'll be using a lot
of spray paint for this project check
out this amazing sculpture where pieces
are sticking out but the white color
makes it look like a truly modern design
project you can even choose a theme for
the toys like this awesome golden lamp
that's full of action figures this lamp
is perfect for a teenage bedroom an
office or a bedroom of any sci-fi fan
toy bookend this next project is pretty
awesome and probably the best one yet
you can create this in many different
ways and with almost all of your toys
did you ever envy your friends awesome
bookends but you never managed to find
the right one this might solve all your
problems
any
definitely something we'll try making -
it's your very own DIY bookend made of
your favorite childhood toys we bet you
still have a couple of action heroes
lying around grab those and find a
wooden block you can polish this block
as much as you want to make it look the
way you want to
then grab your favorite action figure or
any other toy you have you can either
spray paint it or leave it as is use
super glue to stick it on the block and
there you have it your very own toy
bookends you can do this with
practically any toys as well as Lego all
you'll need is to make two l-shaped
brackets out of your Lego bricks and
you're done add a couple of figurines or
anything you like for decoration and
that's all it really takes to make this
work it's quick easy and entirely
inexpensive add it to a kid's bedroom an
office or your living area Barbie hair
salon ever wondered what you could do
with Barbie dolls that are left in your
attic there are a few ways you can make
a Barbie come back to life did you know
that a Barbie doll was first created in
1959 she was named after Ruth handlers
daughter Barbara
handler who was always fascinated with
fashion dolls it's safe to say that the
rest is history over the years we've
seen so many Barbie collections out
there it's hard to keep count so what
can you do with Barbie dolls you are no
longer using our first idea is to give
them a makeover as kids we've always
practiced hair styling skills on our
Barbie dolls but many of us never dared
to cut their hair or color it but now
you can go wild grab a color spray in
some scissors and change the Barbies
hair style into something unique
recycling Barbie dolls is now a thing
and the idea comes from Heder be a
Muslim inspired Barbie wearing a hijab
you can't find these in official Mattel
merchandise but hanifa Adam decided to
put an end to that and created a popular
Instagram account with Barbie hijab
fashion get inspired with your own
Barbie makeovers and challenged all
stereotypes who knows you might even
become Internet
famous what's your favorite childhood
toy let us know in the comments for more
videos like this one check out 10 toys
that weren't supposed to be for kids see
you next time
[Music]